i mean it really is evil i mean
every society throughout human history
has known that you have to protect the
innocence of children every society and
now we are all of a sudden very quickly
in our society okay with removing the
innocence of children i mean that goes
back to the books you know for me it
goes back to what you're seeing at the
strip clubs you know with all these with
i mean it's you're normalizing
pedophilia look let's talk about the
book thing so you know we've seen all
this stuff we have we have a story here
from fox news texas lawmaker planning
bill to ban children from drag shows not
appropriate at all a lot of this is in a
similar vein where for some reason
there's a big push from the left to
expose children to overtly sexualized
activities or avoidly sexual activity
you had a lawsuit um was it just one or
were there two so it's it's kind it's
combined into two there's two different
books that are in this law so you
basically uh
you didn't get them banned no parent or
consent is now required to display
sexual contact that's what we're seeking
yes so
in virginia you're able to uh take a
book before judge um it's it's a law a
year but take a book for judge and make
see if it's obscene so you get a ruling
on it the judge agreed with us uh my
attorney tell uh delegate tim anderson
and i uh decided you know take these
books there's two of them it's the
genderqueer
again the most controversial book in the
country and then court of mist and fury
and we took him before a judge and she
ruled the interesting thing is every
single judge in virginia beach recused
themselves wow said it's political
nightmare they don't do it i'm sorry
guys
you know i talk about civil war conflict
we have a guy who just got arrested for
attempted murder of justice and i and i
say i don't think there's a way out of
this when the judges are like i'm scared
and too cowardly to stand up for values
and the only thing i can see is their
weak men will lead to hard times oh
absolutely always i mean that's what
we're seeing right now quite honestly i
mean whether it doesn't matter what's on
the island you've had some weak
politicians for a long time this book
genderqueer
has
writing some of the writing in it is
overtly sexualized saying i want your in
my and then you have a photograph of two
people performing acts on each other
there's actually two different images of
of activities being performed on each
other adult activities this other book
what was it called court of mist and
fury so what i've not heard this one
though so what's what's so it's actually
it's a it's one of a series uh it's a
three-part series and it's actually
heterosexual nature but the descriptions
of the act of sex
is so descript i mean they can't read so
the local news channel their fm 99
wouldn't wasn't even allowed to read it
on the air was it fcc violation yep
absolutely i know that the lady that was
presenting it uh she's great she was
like why can't read this and so the
other dj's like well let me i'll read it
and look there he goes i can't read this
one there wow but it's okay for sixth
graders to have it 10 to 12 years old
it's okay to give it to our children and
what are they writing these these uh
establishment leftist and liberals are
writing republicans are banning books
i'm a nazi now if you're a book banner
if you believe that you're in a cult i'm
sorry like we don't allow playboy in
schools and playboy isn't like hardcore
stuff right it's you know pinup models
nude women but that's not allowed well
there's got to be a line that's my
that's my point is there has to be a
line
you clearly what for virginia beach
anyway
that school district obviously doesn't
have a clear enough line and i don't
know who it is whoever the failure is
where the breakdown is in administration
and the administrative level level but
whoever it is doesn't have a clear line
so i'm simply asking for parental rights
to be restored so parental consent for
minors to view sexually explicit
material just like when you go to a
movie theater i think one of the issues
is that the whole identity of democrats
is we hate republicans it started partly
with trump i think it existed a little
bit before
but
they said republicans are all bad trump
wins trump is a nazi and now they have
no choice but to stake their identity on
opposing whatever it is that's
right-wing especially if you call
yourself a conservative republican oh i
mean you guys are deserving republicans
are just yeah
so far right yeah i'm like joe rogan
he's a borderline socialist yeah and
they call him right wing because they
have every part of their identity must
be in opposition to whatever it is
maybe the good news is there won't be a
major conflict between factions because
they will ostracize themselves to the
point where there's 10 people who hold
their views
one can only hope right but honestly so
i i actually believe thank you so much
for doing what you're doing honestly i
think this is a step in the right
direction it's going to be complaining
on the internet no it's good but this is
this is where news is now news is no
longer you know fox news or cnn or msnbc
everybody looks at that and realizes
propaganda you had a chinese uh friend
who told me he said we don't watch the
news in china because we know it's
propaganda for some reason you americans
haven't figured it out yet well i heard
that even fox news was pro gun control
they're all pro gun control yeah they're
that i think someone mentioned in super
chats that i'm the five they were in
favor of red flag laws nope
right anybody who pays attention knows
red flag laws just mean a violation of
your fourth amendment rights right
that's it well at one time in the va
they wanted to be able to strip you of
of your gun rights if they thought you
had ptsd right so i don't trust anybody
to be able to tell somebody else what
their mental capacity is i mean we do
that before a judge right but not some
doctor we have no idea what these
doctors are doing i think it's a cra
it's a very dangerous road to go down
for me listen i and when i say that you
certainly run for office people
automatically want to go oh well what
about the kids and everything else
that's happened it's a tragedy these
tragedies are horrible
and you know i think i think all
americans our heartbreaks when we see
this loss of innocent life especially so
young they don't care about kids they
don't care no they don't care at all
there's a great meme i love it it said
it was uh the drake meme you know the
one was putting the hand up and he's
like no and the one was like yes and it
says school shootings it was like oh and
then it says school bombings and he's
like oh right under obama and uh
vice president biden we had kids being
blown up they don't care right what they
care about is they've got a wedge issue
because these things like this happen
all the time now they're like look at
the mass shootings in chicago and
minnesota
you never care about this stuff they
need a wedge issue for the midterms and
so they're acting like they care about
kids but i'll throw it back to what's
going on with these kids in texas
you got a rep in texas and a rep in
florida want to make drag shows illegal
with miners present the funny thing is
it already is
i don't understand how but the cops
won't do anything right these are these
are adult men in in in sexualized
outfits doing sexualized dances with a
big neon sign reading it's not going to
lick itself and the kids are handing
them money for them to dance right there
i'm like okay that's clearly over the
line right then you had desmond is
amazing little boy dancing on stage
stripping his clothes off as gay as
adult gay men are handing him money and
then you have another kid who's called
queen lactatia who was posing with a 99
nude man it's a man who's basically but
a tiny little fabric on his junk and the
little boy's touching like touching his
arm and smiling for the camera
they're they're outright targeting and
abusing kids
and then they're acting like they care
about them and no one else does you know
it's funny because when i talk to people
now um yeah tell me look we hear the
word conservative a lot
but nobody defines why why am i
conservative and i tell people all the
time look i'm a conservative because i
believe there is a transcendent moral
code there's a right and a wrong and
there's a good and evil and i just have
seen evil sweep across this nation for
far too long unchecked and this is what
we're seeing this is the culmination of
it that's that's truly evil
what you're seeing with these kids and
anybody who thinks otherwise is i think
you're just sick honestly
have you seen the documentary what is a
woman the daily i have not seen it i've
seen parts of it seen the whole thing it
is really good it's great they the daily
wire just put out some clips of um they
did an audience screening what do they
call it what are they what do they call
it there's like man i can't think of a
focus group focus group there you go
thank you uh and it was fascinating to
see the shock in regular people's faces
when they were watching this stuff but
there was like one woman she was she was
like there's more than two genders and
and the entire room goes what
like what are you talking about
i think what's happening is
you've got a lot of people who have
their whole identity is based on
opposing whatever the right is and they
live in a media bubble right like you
mentioned msnbc cnn fox news
so they hear these things and they say
okay they think they're the norm they
think they're normal but they're weird
outliers that represent like eight
percent of the population and it's not
just a media bubble it's a social media
oh yeah with the algorithms
regurgitating of political views
amplifying them where people only hear
each other and then the main kind of
disagreement that they may have online
is that someone isn't fighting the other
side too hard or is too sympathetic to
the other side and when you have that
kind of environment you're going to of
course reap a lot of social chaos and i
think a lot of this is being done
deliberately because just even a few
years ago i remember doing independent
media almost 15 years ago and it wasn't
like this this political divide wasn't
like this there was a lot more people in
the middle there was a lot more
moderates there was a lot more people
that were able to see common ground
between the left and the right it wasn't
as hyperbolic as insane as crazy as it
is now where you literally have people
arguing for the abuse of children i mean
it's just so mind-boggling to see so so
it was not that long ago yeah it was not
that long ago i remember it and and you
know i remember even two two and a half
years ago the first time i came on the
show the first thing i said we need a
peaceful divorce and and the
conversation when i brought it up wasn't
even taken seriously he was like yeah
yeah whatever whatever but i was like no
seriously we need a peaceful divorce
because there is no other way to avoid
this larger clash that the ruling elites
are kind of building up so we fight each
other we need we need to stop this
immediately we're going into very
dangerous territory and all the
ingredients all the fuel is being added
to this fire and it's and it's getting
one way you can do that though and i
think roe v wade is a perfect example is
you start you start decentralizing the
federal government reducing federal
government pushing that power back down
to the states people get 50 options
they're going to start migrating to
whatever area they actually decentralize
but that is just geographic polarization
sure what happens if roe v rowe and
casey are overturned republicans win a
majority they win the white house and
then do a federal ban on on abortion
i think it's going to be very impressive
so here's what i what i'll say to both
you guys reading the history of the
civil war what did we see the first
thing that happened was a peaceful
divorce sure before abraham lincoln was
inaugurated
seven states said we hereby secede and
that was it months went by with nothing
they were like that's it we're done and
then abraham lincoln gets in and he goes
i don't i don't recognize that as being
legitimate
fort sumter in south carolina he's got
occupying forces and the states are all
of them are basically like dude you
can't be here right the fight breaks out
and even after the battle of fort sumter
i think it was uh i think it was lee i'm
not sure they didn't know if it was
actually the start of a civil war or
just some small skirmish and that would
be the end of it sure but because of the
actions by the federal government
several other states were like yo
this is crazy what are you doing and
they backed out ended up joining the
confederacy west virginia virginia
splits into two different states so the
other issue is when it comes to the
geographic hyperpolarization as you
described it tommy
the south was angry because laws were
passed the fugitive slave act right that
if slaves escaped to the north the north
had to return them that was federal law
but they didn't the north said no right
now here's here's the issue i think the
north was right not to do it sure i
think slavery was was completely wrong
in amoral it needed to be ended north
many in the north are willing to fight
that fight but because of this southern
state said if the law will not be
respected there is no agreement between
us and you right we leave and that's
what precipitated the secession sure
which ultimately leads to a fight over
weapons which leads to a fight so i i
fear i said this last year
if roe v wade if and roe and casey are
overturned
the republicans
then campaign on banning abortion
federally many think they won't because
republicans are more states rights but
let's say they do
they they they win in november we're
five months out but they can't get past
a filibuster and they won't be able to
get past uh veto sure then donald trump
campaigns and says the first thing i'm
going to do is i'm going to sign the
bill the save the children act and then
he does right then you then you get a
supreme court that is conservative you
get congress and the senate and the
executive branch the bill hits trump's
desks day one he signs it
then you get blue states california
illinois new york who refuse to shut
down abortion clinics
what happens then
will trump send in federal authorities
to do it
will you then get states saying we will
not recognize federal law enforcement
will it result in conflict over his
clinics i'd be willing to bet antifa and
other left-wing groups would show up oh
sure fight with federal authorities at
abortion clinics i'm not saying it will
happen i'm not saying it's like yeah i
think that's the i think that's the most
extreme case obviously but
if you took that power and you push it
back down to states where i think it
belongs
i think our forefathers would say that
kind of power belongs to the state not
the federal level the federal level the
federal government has just become this
all-consuming beast that thinks that and
and people the vast majority of
americans go well let's just let the
government legislate why they've done a
poor very poor job of it why are we
going to trust that we push that power
back down as low as possible to the
states or local localities and that's
where we had the most say that's always
what i'm an advocate for i i do agree i
think um
it may be the only option we have so i
was asked by this progressive what i
thought about roe v wade and i'm like
i'm pro-choice
but i think at this point the best thing
we can do is let states be states sure
conservatives can go to red states and
then blue states can go to blue you know
blue people go to blue states or
whatever my answer's the same except i'm
pro-life and i think you should be down
to the states you know i'd still be look
i believe that life begins at conception
so i would always you know seek to push
the needle in that direction however i
think it's a state rights issue i don't
think it's a federal issue i really
don't and i've had people go oh you're
just you're pushing you're passing the
buck i'm like i'm not passing that but
i'm giving you 50 options i think it's
the safest it's the nicest thing to do
the most compassionate thing that we do
to people give them 50 options yeah i
think what we're talking about is just
decentralization yeah absolutely and i
think the more we allow individuals to
make the right decisions for themselves
the more we win whenever we have a big
bureaucratic government we have a
government that of course rules for the
many and makes many mistakes right um
and i think that's exactly what we have
right now we have way too much money
invested in it we have way too much
policies we have way too many decisions
being made by this bureaucratic becky
force that doesn't give a damn about the
average person and is serving the needs
of the special ruling class and helping
them out i promise the ruling class too
i mean let's be honest i mean it's we're
supposed to be a constitutional republic
instead where we've become this you've
got this weird time going on
technocratic uh corporacy uh run by
bankers and shadowy elites a lot of c's
but yeah
you know what it feels like it feels
like you know wealth only lasts a few
generations they say three generations
and it feels like the ruling elites the
the politicians the the the the wealthy
kids they're not good at running these
institutions and organizations so you
look at everything and you're like why
does it feel like these things are
falling apart it's like oh we used to
have oligarchs and ruling elites and
barons
their their great grandkids have no idea
how to run this stuff and it's all just
collapsing around them right no you're
absolutely right i mean but it's it's a
problem when you have these congressmen
and congresswoman going into congress
not worth anything and then four years
later worth 10 million dollars that's a
problem
where did you get that from i know what
your budget was i don't know what your
salary was and there's no way even if
you didn't spend a single
just just i guess people are saying you
got to invest where nancy pelosi invests
because she knows something hey i said
you know you know how to be the the uh
the most favorite congressman in all of
the nation every single one every single
week just say these are my investment
opportunities
yeah we got a bunch of bills on our desk
here's how they're going to vote on them
here's what i'm about here's what i'm
investing you're going to say that hey
this is what i'm investing in yeah there
was entire tick tock channels just built
on what nancy pelosi was trading in the
stock market that got censored and
deleted and taken down well listen i
mean it's criminal you know i mean
absolutely
martha stewart went to jail for it come
on you know i mean if martha stewart can
go to jail for what are we doing here
but we do have to i think we just have
to elect the right people i really do
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast if you
want to watch live you can check out
this channel monday through friday at
8pm and don't forget to smash that like
button subscribe to this channel and if
you want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests
go to timcast.com and become a member
all of these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time